where are we at right now we've been
looking at these exponential functions
and their two brothers felt logarithms
and now we're going to differentiate and
integrate functions related to them it
just sort of opens up a whole new
category of different kinds of homes
that we don't have to deal with all of
the curve sketching stuff all of the
working out areas
I suppose if we want to volume or
anything to do with Exponential's a lot
of you now have access to so here's a
quick example and what I love about this
is the amount of information you get
it's so vanishingly small but you can
still work out everything you need
adjustment map okay so they give us a
curve they say between this curve and
the corner axes what area here is done
what's the size of that area that's you
complicated question but even though
it's not said you really need to get a
particular board right like how do you
even know where this thing is and how
these relate until you get a picture
okay
so anyone have crack an explained to me
like without putting pen to paper how
would you describe this curve that
you've been given do some words of this
below the okay very good
so I'd be enough I've been moved down
have enough that's the the minus eight
has given me a vertical shift that way
and of course in DX we know exactly what
that shape looks like something's been
t-this kind of being right because if
the X usually has a horizontal asymptote
at y equals zero this will have a
horizontal Center at y equals negative
eight very good so I'm gonna pop that in
yeah I've got mine y y equals negative 8
okay so that looks good
what other kinds of values can I put
onto q I've got some intercepts right
will they be useful to me
now I'm gonna pause for a second and ask
which intercepts are going to be useful
to me because I'm not just gonna put one
stuff just because it's there I want to
do remember I said you do the least
amount possible classic mathematical
business in order to actually answer the
question for instance I mean your wife
says it's usually a kind of you should
the important thing to know but what
rather this is a half of this crap yeah
I don't actually need the y-intercept do
i I mean if I wanted to integrate with
respect to the y-axis I would need
someone down there easy right but I mean
what why would you there's there's no
need to go to an unusual way of
approaching the area like that if I'm
thinking about this corner axis here
that's the X 1 axis this axis here the y
axis that you can see you can see the
area that your octave right here is
that's the one what there's no reason
why I can't just compare that to the x
axis so what I should have is X
boundaries so what's the first thing
powdery see right that's an easy one
okay the second it's not as obvious yeah
I'm gonna let y equal zero that can give
you the Exodus that's right so if y
equals zero something right here for y y
be 0 just gonna solve that so leave the
X take away equals 0 e to the x equals
needs to exit course is equal to could
you ask for any simpler boundaries okay
so now that I have that I can form it
integral but be careful be careful
what's the actual area that I'm after
it's going to be like it's this great
space here
right but before you touch an integral
you know that the inter was gonna hand
you a negative number right because the
entire area is below the axis okay so
I'm not going to say area equals I know
it's a very slightly nuanced thing but
I'm just gonna call this thing I'm about
to work out I'll call it a blue excuse
me and it's not the actual area I want
it's going to give me the negative of
the area that I want because boy the
axis so if I can say no hey this is the
actual integral ending you've no box
did you go far what are we just saying
one of any X take away a mean effective
X okay are you happy with that
so we just done all the all the
groundwork to say okay now I know when
I'm working and now I just focus on the
presence of actually integrating sir
square project we've just laboured the
fact that either the X when you
integrate it becomes in X what does big
yeah it's it's just a constant right so
it'll be minus e X just the straight
line of your result and that you're
integrating from naught to one we ready
to worry about any constants because
it's uh what kind of it's definite to
provide it's not critical plus C in here
if I wanted to do but it's gonna get
patted and then subtracted so that's why
it matches away okay let's just quickly
evaluate so it's not even the one
takeaway eighty times one amen yeah but
can I just make a good right these are
the six is so easy to just like you're
in the fire again when you're evaluating
right hand um yeah yeah that's right so
just yeah be careful right that's why
this step it helps you it stuff like a
debugging point of use if it's okay I
know this is exactly right because all I
did was substitute haven't done any
evaluation or super for you take away
and I bet evaluate at the lower bound
which of course also has its own value
okay so what I got here I've got eighty
take away a
- one take away a zero and that whole
thing is negative what just as we were
expecting because it's below the axis
right so now I'm gonna run out of space
I'm usually put this on me but the
actual area that I want is what you
display yeah really I mean that your
diagram is your explanation right you
know how much I talk about diagrams
right if your diagram looks that good it
is clear that once you get funky is
below the axis and what you're actually
looking for is an area which is the bags
you wear I suppose you might want to
start saying it's nothing like being
more verbal about it is if I've got like
different areas like different regions
parts above parts below the changes back
and forth I'm gonna want to say things
like at this point a is an integral
below the axis so it represents a
negative number and then I might have
silence that might be a 1 a 2 is
positive so I'll just take that number
and if there's lots of different pieces
like the complexity of the question
tells me how much I need to explain okay
so I'm trying to avoid giving you like a
hard and fast rule like you must always
write a sentence or you must always put
absolute value well it kind of depends
on what the question is okay so I might
I might say I mean one way of
approaching this is just a one absolute
value signs around this and then just go
for it I have described before why I try
to avoid that because it's kind of like
I want to know that it's a negative
number because I know what that means
from my pick shop what that means so
it's not like I'm just indiscriminately
pretty good absolute value cause our
rule told me sir I think this is
perfectly sufficient